I need to ask you guys so in college I
heard if you put alcohol in your butt it
gets drunk faster ever did that no but
that's genius cuz you're not consuming
it so your body doesn't need excuse me
digest it but the big thing also is it
does doesn't come up on your breath yeah
but I like I never knew anyone who
actually tried it and I wanted to know
was it real straight to blood did you
know they ever did that no not at AR no
wow how did that but what how do you put
it up there like no homo like like a
tampon so you soak a Tamp in yeah I
didn't even hear that I thought he just
just tooted and
boot like that's what I was thinking who
who why you trying to but up you put a
funnel I'll just have one glass let me
just start drink after Alex media bro
the tip of that one ball I never did it
Ball's going to smell disg always
wondered what year is this this is a
[__] 83 what drugs we want to do what
drugs no I mean like it like we we tried
a decent amount of drugs yeah and they
have created some cool
experiences are there any ones that we
like is there anything that you haven't
done you want to do ones that you want
to do again I IAS is the only one I did
acid one time it was a phenomenal
experience but I don't I don't need to
do it again in uh at Bernie man no no no
acid I didn't do at what was the one
that you were on top of the [__] uh
[__] uh
theem but um yeah just iow Oscar is the
only thing I want to do at this point I
don't I don't want anything you have to
inject into yourself might be too
intense bro remember when grah hanock
was saying the dude was trying to steal
his soul or whatever yeah but it made
Neil a nice
guy if you can BR a nice guy I got happy
dude we might have to try this a good
point okay iasa you go I don't know I
mean arier said the only one that he
never did that he would want to do is
heroin I think he's like cuz you can't
do it because then you're hooked forever
but that's why it's so sick that's why I
won't do that can can I white
people so here's the thing the drugs
that I'm interested go the drugs that
I'm interested in
doing are not individualistic drugs MH
heroin is very individualistic yeah you
want communal iasa is individualistic
maybe you can do with other people and
connect I'm not exactly sure but just
from talking to people it's not exactly
like that it's more like oh I'm going to
face these demons or I'm going to talk
to my grandparents blah blah it's all
about like inside I prefer communal so
like smoking weed with friends is funny
just like laughing and joking Molly With
Friends is incredible um alcohol yeah is
the most communal drug ever it's awesome
yeah so if there's something else in
that realm that induces that like great
communal hang and lowers everybody's
inhibitions
about their camaraderie and affection
for one another
I'm down to do it if it's just oh my God
I'm so high or oh my God I feel so good
or oh my God I'm not as interested in it
m I think those are all the communal
drugs right yeah but yeah I guess that's
why like even with mushrooms I never
like Dove has mushrooms and sometimes
and he's like yeah I can still hang and
I can still party I'm like n you check
out you think you can but you check out
from the group it's introspective yeah I
don't want to do mushrooms with you yeah
I don't like maybe I'm just not at that
point in my life where I'm like I I
spend a lot of time in here yeah that's
the only reason I drink I don't drink
cuz I'm like oh I love getting drunk I
like hanging with the boys yeah boys
drunk is great it's the best I've never
drank alone I've never drank alone in my
life yeah you need you need the vibe I
need literally someone else to be like
dude let's [__] do this yeah so yeah
I think yeah when it comes to the drugs
maybe that's what's tempered my
curiosity in trying some of these things
like acid I don't care about seeing all
those things and being isolated from my
friends yeah I would rather do
Molly I'd rather do even Aderall is
basically just giving me some energy so
I have more yeah awake hours to party
with the boy to hang it's about to hang
yeah so is there anything else we're
missing that's improves the hang in some
way I mean alcohol is number one though
it's the best why people do alcohol then
Coke and camine to sort of like keep the
[__] keep it going but did does ketamine
do that like I tried to ketamine that
[__] didn't
really it it didn't do anything to me I
don't really feel yeah which one
ketamine ketamine like what did ketamine
do to you it slowed me the [__] down but
did you still feel like you
were
communal uh basically what I said to
them was I don't know if you're here for
that part but like I'm curious in the
drugs that are communal heroin would be
just about me you know all these other
on just about me Molly is communal you
know even Coke I don't do because I
think I have stigma there's like a I
grew up in a time where it was still
very stigmatized I know now it's just
like a party drug for kids like they do
it like alcohol it's just hey let's stay
up a little bit longer and do some coke
I I'm old so I'm carrying whatever
weight that we had on the drug into it
but
um but yeah I I just have no like even
mushrooms I have no you ever be people
that do cocaine alone no I I talked to a
dude the other day that was like I can't
do cocaine because if I do cocaine at a
party then I'll immediately leave and
then just go to my apartment and do
cocaine alone I had a roommate in
college to do this come home air
conditioning dropped super low this is
how you knew it was going on every light
in the house is on you look down the
block and the whole house is lit up you
come home all the doors are locked and
the air conditioning super low all the
lights are on music is playing so loudly
in the house all the mirrors are off the
wall and he's just upstairs [__]
smoking cigarettes doing cocaine that's
a school
shooter like that's strange bro he just
loved the rock music and then you'd grab
a cigarette and he'd stay up all night
with it that's now was is that guy an
introver
um a
bit I'll edit it yeah prob yeah more in
that's what I think I think that like a
lot of times drugs are just going to
make you more comfortable in the state
that you already want to exist in all
right guys you know what time it is you
see the lights it's time to talk about
blue CH one of our original sponsors OG
flagrant and you know why we stayed with
them because it works if you want to be
better at sex if you want to give your
best performance performance enhancing
drugs for the most important performance
blue two is what you need ladies why not
treat yourselves to the night of your
lives by giving the man you care about
at least for one night blue Che and if
you're a flagrant fan you know what you
know what the deal is also Flavin hooks
it up on the promo special deal for deal
for our listeners you try blueo for free
when you use our promo code flagrant at
checkout you just got to pay $5 shipping
that's bluechew.com promo code flagrant
and you'll get your first month for free
first month for free one month great sex
I used up my month and I'm still coming
back for blue
cuz my dick game without it bus Huda
anyway visit blue.com for more details
and important safety information cuz we
don't want you having great sex without
being safe blue Chu looking out for you
and thank you blue Chu always for always
sponsoring this podcast now let's get
back to the show I like alcohol because
I'm pretty much an introvert and it's
like it loosens me up and makes me more
of an extrovert oh we know it loosens
you
up so here's the thing about about you
though like y laugh too all right
your I feel like your
state I don't know if if you're an
introvert in that you want to be
introverted like there are some people
that they want to be alone and they want
to have alone time I don't know if
that's you I think you want to connect
with people and I think you want to and
then sometimes the drugs are going to
make it even easier yeah but that is a
desire for you Jam's wedding I hit about
15 minutes you're like I'm just a little
know these people like too much even
though you had the boys and everything
there but if you have few drinks now
you're just talking to everybody
everything's easy and good that so that
is
the that makes sense to me L hooka is a
great social drug son yeah right another
thing Muslims figured out they [__] hang
around with the boysit
Dominicans the but yo actually that's
it's not surprising to me that the uh
that the Latinos [__] with hookah like
that why because the hang on the corner
on the stoop outside the building was
hookah without hookah yeah you just have
an excuse
yeah exactly we're going to do it
regardless now they just now there's an
activity like if like do you want to
hang on the street no that sounds whack
yo you guys want to go hit the hookah of
course where we doing it on the street
street they're the only people I know
that own multiple hookas inside their
house and they put them up like like
decoration I don't know anyone else I
love when they decorate the interior
decor with hookas that's amazing that's
like like frat kids would decorate with
empty uh liquor
bot that's how you know there's like
four Dudes live together it's just like
all the alcohol bottles lined up I miss
what you said about ketamine well how
does ketamine make you feel me it's like
it slows things up so much it doesn't
make me like communal I don't want to
like it kind of just slows things to a
point where it's like
I'm feel that's why I understand the
music because it slows that music where
it's like oh it's almost sounding like
don't it's like it's like a cool
somebody said to me that ketamine is
just uh it creates like a
detachedness without the insecurity of
being detached so like you get to
disassociate usually like we're all
hanging out and if I start
disassociating
it's kind of like awkward like I'm like
an awkward dude around you so and I'm
aware that I'm being awkward and now I
feel insecure about disassociating like
even going to the bathroom is
disassociative yeah I just hope no one
notice ex but I think the ketamine
removes the
insecurity of the disassociation and now
you're chilling with people there's
music you're around everybody but you
get to be in your own Zone without the
the fear that people are going to think
you're weird or awkward which is a
great great utility in a drug yeah if
that's what you want to do but once once
again I think that like I I would rather
oh yeah I like uppers like uppers yeah
like I want to are there any more what's
tusi I keep hearing about toi what is
that is that one crazy uh just it's Coke
it actually depending on where you get
it but it changes you know how drugs are
pred pill like no no no it's uh powder
it's usually either pink or blue uh it's
just Coke and Molly so just think about
those two amazing the best feelings ever
together yeah oh like that's why it's
like and you snort it or you or you uh
snort yeah it's powder I know a drug I
want to do that's what I'm saying it's
just too good but it's one of those like
chill cuz that can become incredibly
yeah yeah yeah yeah I want just like
they need that just to go what you want
to do what I want to do quut they they
don't exist anymore like it's like on
forever [__] that so cool but that's
another one that's just going to check
you out yeah it's like but now that it's
not existant I'm like one more time one
more trip the way people used to talk
about it was crazy you talk to an old
person that did quo back day what he say
just like dude that's the best W stre
the whole movie he did he had 10,000 qus
in his life he says and that's like an
actual stat he says but what is it what
is the what happens it's like a horse
Tran right it's like the idea two xans
you would EXA probably feel the same way
like cuz in the movie he's like
basically what happen what people
figured out is if you cannot go to sleep
from the qualude yeah then you get a
high after you push through most people
pass out from the quu because it's a a
tranquilizer what's that sleeping drug
oh ambient Ambient oh is that the same
[__] ambient High people do if you can
push through the sleepy then you're high
and you're like
reallyy you see the dude's doing cop
syrup at uh Top Golf no you didn't see
the most fire video Rob yeah literally
or like Walk Hard they're like pouring
it in the thing like in the Sprite and
they're like on at Top Golf like on the
te's and Sip and lean and they kick them
out and they're like are you racist and
they're like no you just can't do drugs
here he's like come on
bro come on why why why you hating on me
it's the most unreal videos Manny
Switzerland said they were going to I
never did legal or something I never did
Lean I never did Lean either and I have
no interest yeah yeah sprite's the best
part M give me a Sprite I'll be [__]
Jolly ranch give me that sweet have we
done all the drugs man we kind of like
we done them all do we need new ones
make a new one up dude I think we did
them all yeah we were just talking about
the rich kids that are like yo what do
we what do you do at the end and you're
like come on where the drugs at I feel
bad for these rich kids you just got to
find them ones that you like locking on
those and keep it at a nice little and
then play more p
and that's that's life I'll be honest it
changes your life man that's life that's
your drug yeah just having a thing that
you love doing like obviously we
have I don't like zans wait why why what
does xans do you just feel like you're I
you just feel like you're a superum you
just feel like you could do anything you
have energy or you just not energy it's
just that my you go oh yeah but you get
anxiety so if you could just reduce that
completely you're on fire yeah I'm like
[__] I'll do anything to me it's not
like I'm super human I could walk
through bullets it's like oh could you
solve this issue or do you think you
could go talk to that person or like
handle this situation I'm like anything
so there's no second guessing yeah you
ride a bull for eight seconds I don't
know if it's
like y' might be on Xanax bro y' might
be on xic naturally you have natural
close right close you have natural xans
all the time so you really don't think
you could ride a bull for at least 4
seconds no if it's like a old shitty
tiny
yes maybe yeah maybe I just think they
ain't want it
enough okay this is they wanted if you
hold on can can you can you just tell me
one thing real quick what the [__]
is guy gets stuck in a vas oh this is an
awesome video this guy had a New Year's
Eve party thought it' be funny if he
like jumped in a big flower pot wait
he's in a flower pot right now yeah my
mom had one and then is he doing what he
got
stuck wait wait oh he can't get out he's
drunk and he got stuck in a flower pot
my mom had that same flower pot I mean
I'm breaking that
[__] like is it his stomach just too big
to get I think his knees got stuck yeah
I don't think he can unbend his
knees now you see the [__] he's dealing
with his mouth that tells me this is not
dress
alcohol this is what happens bro this is
your America that you want Al I I'm just
saying it looks like he's a little bit
got out
nope yo this is
hilarious Americans are the best I will
I bet you I can get in that
vase I'll bet yall
could
that's awesome so this is awesome but to
me it just doesn't make sense they get
him out in they got him out they got him
out without breaking it they they hit
him they hit him from the back and they
got him out oh they broke
it yo give me some patreon question
right the [__] how unreal is this
dude alltime legendary [__] party yo
remember when Connor got stuck in a vase
for three hours that's [__] unreal
you whites know how to have fun I really
do know how to have fun that's awesome
we try